dans la configuration en fait du stream
mais non ça va être bon maintenant alors
j'ai essayé d'ouvrir le chat mais du
coup ça a bien marché puisque avant ça
aurait pu me guay je vais essayer de
voir le chat ça marche je vois que le
stream est reparti ça c'est un peu la
bonne nouvelle est en revanche j'arrive
pas ouvrir le chat a on va essayer de
seuil et d'y arriver en faire une
deuxième tentative nous sort on va faire
des beats acat avec fanien fabien qui va
arriver d'une minute à l'autre
il va arriver rapidement et vraiment je
n'avais pas ouvrir le chat ça va bientôt
être chauffe ça va bientôt être chose
faite
si je ne dois pas trop
alors oui comme chat hockey et on va
faire papa août comme ça on va obtenir
le chat
qui va s'ouvrir devant mes yeux avec un
film et c'est qu'ils me disent à lui
donc salut à toi pendant sa marche donc
ça c'est une bonne chose de faite et la
deuxième chose à faire en attendant
fabien ça va être d'ouvrir che ce point
comme tv sans se met en place
tranquillement avant de démarrer à noter
que maxime vient de gagner la partie
contre contre cramique il vient de
l'emporter je vous montrais la position
finale du coup pendant que vous ça de
l'autre côté
pendant que j'ouvre ça de l'autre côté
à l'arrivée ou voilà ici maxime qui a
gagné une finale deux tours contre
kramnik bonsoir thomas mutsch 2003 et
donc ça c'est la partie 2-2 maxime donc
se terminer comme ça avec ici surtout
reprend harkati crown qui arrive le tour
prend h4 un petit roi b 5 échecs
découverte qui aurait permis à maxime de
prendre la tour au coup suivant
c'est pour ça que cramique a abandonné
le roi bouge par exemple le roi bien
prendre à 4 et le pion à et instoppable
alors comment on gagne ça exactement
plein de moyen le plus simple c'est
peut-être juste de faire droit à cinq
jours j'ai cinq tours ici j'ai quatre
tours ici pour le stopper par exemple et
puis après on pousse le pion à ses états
à 7 assists par exemple ou si il vient
protéger avec son roi on peut du coup
poster sicilien mettre sa tour derrière
on vient se mettre comme ça et après de
toute façon au pire des cas on peut tour
toujours sacrifié la tour contre le pion
ici puisque comme on a deux pions va
réussir à finir avec une dame de plus
donc assez facile à gagner plus faire un
petit peu attention mais c'est pas c'est
pas un problème de gagner cette position
maxime qui a gagné et on va regarder ce
qui se passe dans ma partie carlos elle
contrecarre yakine hors matériel un peu
bizarre on a tous réunion compte deux
pièces le roi de kayak keane paraît être
en danger à première vue mais
bizarrement le cavalier tient pas mal de
cases hyper importante genre couplé avec
le fou en fait ils tiennent un peu tout
et je me demande si les tours 2
de carlson peuvent vraiment faire grand
chose surtout qui est une menace quand
même qui est de faire dame prendre des
cinq échecs me demande si karl scène
encore mieux ici en fait les grosses
questions pour moi je sais pas s'il
encore mieux en fait on n'a pas
forcément un
on n'a pas forcément le l'ordinateur ici
mais du coup du coup pas facile à jouer
pour les blancs je sais pas est ce qu'on
peut ce que dame prend des cinq quand
même pénible à ne plus attaquer deux
fois et genre si on fait un truc comme
auquel a fait tour à schwyz
ah ok surtout rachis 3g 7 reprend 1,8 à
la base je pensais qu'ils auraient dame
prend f dame prend ici pour faire une
double attaque mais le problème c'est
que y'a dame f3 qui couvrent et du coup
on protège la tour donc tourache 8
forces plus ou moins calés g8 web forces
plus ou moins qu'avec g8 j'imagine parce
que suroît g7 vraiment un tour prend à 8
je vois pas vraiment manquer dont
cavaliers g8
youkai g8 on a toujours la menace d'un
prend des cinq qui va forcément défendre
le pion il va forcément défendre le pion
ici
[Musique]
des tours 4
alors probablement sur dame prend des 5
son idée c'est tuer dame prend à f3
damèche 3 pardon et du coup ils menacent
tour 8es dame prend des 5 et 6 la dame
s'en va quelque part georges c'est pas
moi dame voilée on va dire damas un
colza rhin il va y avoir un truc du type
et peut-être même mieux mais du type
corps tout reprend prix / g 4 échecs et
dame prend 1,8 à la fin donc on va
gagner du matériel au pire comme ça donc
faire tour 4 pas mal joué et dans pas
mal de variantes il peut commencer à
menacer tour j'ai quatre tours prend
bonbons surtout rejet car il ya
peut-être dame prend des cinq mais ça va
commencer a menacé ça commence à menacer
tous les tours g4 et du cou
et du coup du coup ma sueur g4 qui peut
arriver rapidement
il faut jouer précis il faut jouer
précis pour les noirs en fait pas débat
j'avais pas vu en fait tous rage suite
avec cette idée avec cette idée c'est
pour ça que j'avais l'impression que
c'était pas si grave
mais là du coup c'est assez pénible
quand même mais ce qui est encore
d'autres partir en jeu ou pas donc
maxime a gagné et il ya aussi guiry on
va aller voir guiry
ighirri du coup
qui du coup il a un pion plus évidemment
guéri qui joue pour gagner
ça doit être gagnant ça à mon avis on
attend ya fabien qui arrive comme ça
c'est le skype salut fab
ouais ça ça y est on t'entend est ce que
tu peux mettre ta caméra s'il te plait
monsieur monsieur fabien enfin regarder
que maxime a gagné que guy est gagnant
apparemment et carl scène j'ai du mal à
évaluer difficile sur l'ordinateur à ces
tactiques comme position mairie doit
être mieux lorsqu'elle joue pour le gain
mais à quel point j'en sais rien alors
je dis enfin je veux dire c'est à dire
ce que j'en pense surtout que l'on
s'assure sûrement rien non plus on va
lui mais la camtel et le partage d'écran
ou je sais pas quoi vos jeux suivants
non ce qu'avec le beats akhatova commun
faire du beats à quatre on va on va
caméra mines il faut que faut que tu fu
taille devenir d'une fois par exemple on
peut voir que tu te connectes et tout ça
fabien qui l'a alors il faut juste qu'on
les sorte chose comme en vrai tout
bêtement fait bon ça peut être signé
demain l'entraîneur c'est gagné pour le
nouvel entraîneur vue alors on avait
fait un gros coup au web une puce ou
alors tu es comme qu'est-ce que je fume
je jouais alors à ton regard déjà les
parties ouais mais ici c'est sûr jouer
ses jumelles non oui tu assures jumelles
alors guy garand annoncé la première
chose rare
[Musique]
non mais je pense que ça gagne au
guetsch dopage je peux bien sûr nous tue
paris / nul 1 1 au prix du poisson qui
éditeront moi je pense que c'est gagnant
légué des 334 et du cou
sur mes pas m'ont peut pas faire sans
des trois nobel juste fort que nous au
rejet 3 mais j'ai pas le temps de faire
le truc avec attend qui a été 3 g iii
kf4 prise prise à ce podium
non je sais pas juste ok jeunes on se
demande si ça ça marche pas avons signé
des choses qui les laisse au g3 kf4
m'attend je la met à l'écran qu'elle est
3g trois cavaliers f4 prise prise
ok ça c'est bien comment tu gagnes ça du
coup après puis en janvier mois en fait
tu fais rien de bien neuf sur dix
veulent bien faire f3 à f2 f1 ouais
ouais
bref cette jeu d'échecs c4 et puis c'est
bon tout est bloqué ok mais bon c'est
cette défense ne marche pas du coup tu
te rejoins et je pense de diender
maintenant il faut être précis quand il
faut faire pousser 4 au moment où il
fait j'en faisais ça fait faire x 2 pour
rejoindre phase iii vous importe où ces
4es du coup en fait si froid recettes
ont fait rage et cissé on passe devant
et ça gagne et si f1 dames ont fait fou
prend un air frais sur walf 7 pouces et
quatre échecs et du coup on bloque
toutes les cases d'accès on bloque toute
légalité et du cou
très possible que ça gagne hockey maxime
a gagné et du coup la partie de carlson
question pensent en concert les beats à
4 personnes éventuellement plus tendue
car al sadd mais j'ai bien aimé son
dernier coup tours 4 je pense qu'il va
gagner il est très énervé ce n'est pas
du tout content mais on devait revient
en fait ces menaces parle de trucs genre
d'armes f3 tour g4 la pénible apparaît
après tout cas des qin qui j'ai toujours
prêt à défendre tout c'est jamais bon
visuellement ça quand même l'air pas mal
du tout retrait active piste noire
complètement la rue du jeu
tu as bien ça pour les blancs je pense
ce bien en dessous permet de remettre à
tour j'ai cassé par est juste difficile
apparaît en fait après sa victoire
yakine trouve toujours des trucs
peut-être des dames g7 j'ai pas pour
rentrer dans des finales
non mais c'est le gagnant bageois mal
trop ce qu'on fait ce que même tour
gygax ils menacent quelque peu d'hommes
prend des cinq échecs ok mais rouages
depuis outlook ou non ça c'est vrai une
mais ok si je fais d'alger ça que c'est
dans cette position là ouais je fais
immédiatement d'alger 7e
j'ai un objectif de mettre en pls
e est ce que je veux dire par est dingue
way to reprend g8
ouais c'est ça que je regarde à prendre
avec la dame de mont royal tours g4 et
bénéfices non merci saint victor g4
simplement gay dans tout ça en fait je
pensais même pas tout amelia tête
d'alger 6 ha ok mais sinon j'ai conçu
par tanger quatre ans un patator g8
d'hommes g8 torje 4 6 6 1
nous ne nous racheter mais fou et 7 non
mais en fait on a dû trouver damas tech
tour h4 bah oui les gars je suis tenace
fait bon se doit ni ne doit guère douga
c'est la dernière ligne si ça va parler
mars suisse unis donc du coup alors
attends je vais est invitée à faire
affaire du bullet alors attention du
pizza 4 attention alors plus fade libye
tombe ce ces familles mais on est
d'accord
ouais le point barre des 1200 bas j'ai
jamais joué mais c'est pas à toi tu
étais pas d'hier était non mais tombe
sur trois indiens je sais pas je les
vois je suis et je veux pas que je suis
un bon le truc est tellement je ne sais
pas ce que je m'attends family attends
je vais essayer parmi les seules ou en
train non c'est toi
mais comment se sait je n'ai pas mon
truc et je les accueille surtout un
teckel
il n'y a que quand ils veulent en a pas
du coup foot accepte je n'ai aucune
notification je n'ai rien bah si si si
temps incité dans le travail non mais je
suis partie du coût pour essayer de
trouver merde tu reviennes ces machins
partenaires voile et j'accepte vous avez
plutôt breton partenariat à la partie
oui c'est parti alors attends j'ai eu
six décès de trois minutes
ouai ouai c'est trop bien désormais
c'est quoi mais c'est un v8 mais ça
bouge mais daikin effet gafsa leurs 5 4
et je vois ton échiquier à côté ouais
c'est moi je suis là alors attendre du
coup moi il faut que je re caméra min ou
parce que ça a décalé l'échiquier on ne
voit plus rien du cours et sont les
pièces que je peux poser à mais je ne
pourrais me poser je n'ai rien pris en
revanche moi je peux poser un pion
adversaires ne joue pas mon adversaire
ne joue pas bon c'est pas me faire mal
et trop vite donc non ça c'est ça et du
coup en fait c'est très très bien parce
que je vais en profiter en fait pour que
les gens puissent un [ __ ] si j'ai un
pur jeu le posant h3 je suis hyper
content mais tu n'as pas tueur j'attends
g que ces six secondes dans n'importe où
je joue aux échecs mais lui aussi la
patrie en fait non plus le reste un
blitz norman actuellement bas donc c'est
absolument inintéressant des déchets à
tanger j'essaye de j'essaye de bien
faire les choses là fabien je suis je
suis en plein champ pleine panique là on
a gagné par interruption deux parties
n'ont joué contre on jouait pas contre
des parts contre des génies des mecs
n'ont pas ne pas jouer n'importe qui
aurait pu les battre
alors j'essaie de mettre ton écran allez
hop comme ça les gens vont pouvoir voir
le bit sa carte mais très très content
et après on est prêt
j'avais vu sur nouvelle trois minutes où
je fais rien tu fais rien c'est bon
c'est parce est reparti allez hop on est
bon alors je les american way attendu ne
gagnent 2,5 avant qu est ce qui me fait
pousser 4 je fais quoi allez-vous me
prends moi le cavalier je savais qu'à
aller je développe mes pièces maintenant
dégage nous mettons un fichier stic boom
qui ont des singes avec ton cavaliers je
veux plus te voir
boom boom alors à temps qu'est ce que
j'ai dans les mains d'un [ __ ] tu as
besoin de quoi est ce que tu as besoin
de toi je sais pas je repars chez moi je
ne veux pas me faire sacrifier mais si
je prends ça je dis non ballard a tant
matériellement un [ __ ] ça me saoule
quoi ils me posent des pions dans la
gueule quoi
ouais mais ils ont également l'air
d'être affûté avec deux amerloques non
mais ne joue pas surtout nous faire
l'échangé ne joue pas on attend qu'est
ce que c'est comme un petit gars fait
faire d'autre je suis très très content
bon bah je vais jouer un jeu pose un
melon je le plains de mes trucs j'en ai
marre il va pas me fatiguer l'américain
tu poses et 1 fois et c'est cool que tu
me donnes un fou ça va beaucoup m'aider
bon alors nous en plein échange massif
chez moi je suis pas super bien là à les
supposer un futur échec comme ça je vais
reprendre le pion je suis pas moi si je
crois quoi c'est moi qui me fais
attaquer en fait ça m'énerve
peut-être que je vais être au matériel
ben non mais c'est juste moi qui ai les
pièces mal placé je sais pas à tien je
vais me matter c'est bon c'est bon c'est
bon c'est fini c'est fini tu peux
arrêter jeu malheureusement ok donc je
suis pas macho
ouais moi j'ai pris le jeu près move
je suis bien à l'elysée une prime on a
gagné
les blancs et l'horreur on joue la
défense avec les blancs ouais j'suis
défense je ne sais pas attaquer à ce bon
bâton pilote à l'armée faisant attaquer
scandinaves ou italienne le roquet en
fait j'étais en train de me dire que tu
es y perdu là ce jeu oui je vous dis
jamais jouer à wii donc en fait c'est
très embêtant bas la norme tu vas
pouvoir attaquer comme un malade parce
que tu es en train de te filer une dame
et c'est fantastique là pour toi
normalement on peut pas poser sur pro tu
poses survenant en vertu posé sur matt
par johan personnel qu'elle veut mettre
un pion direct je te pousse de jeu pour
jeux promotionnels comme fer que tu
progresses parce que sinon ça va pas le
faire mais là on est très très bien je
pense que je pense qu'on est
complètement gagné en fait
je vais pas lui donner une mélodie me
fait de le reconstituer moi je ne
comprends pas prête et pas les prendre
le car à y en a à g 8 pour la ctf sept
matches noble du mot bombe ce ne sont
pas des choses qui vient d'esprit envers
les pièces que j'ai sous les yeux bon je
reconstitue mort du coup le rock est
reconstituée je vois ta partie en fait
voilà le mec m'attaque il tait constitue
mon roc en fait
haifa tu fais très attention tu peux te
prendre un rush un chemin je me trompe
ça fait mal prend à ses passifs allait
reprendre une 2e fois d'aller là bas
sinon il peut me donne deux manches
ouais calcul si t'as pas des matches si
t'as pas des trucs on n'est pas très
bien auquel je dois me we keep leurs
yeux plus pointus mais si je suis pas
super rassurer pour moi
le mec me pose plein de pièces sur le
roi j'arrive pas à l'attaquer c'est la
paix à l'aise chez plein de caisse dans
la main je n'arrive pas à les mettre
faut que tu fasses efforts je savais
faire
je suis très intéressant je peux pas te
dire j'avais posé un truc que j'avais en
main surtout surtout pas d'échangé
d'armes incité changé d'âme je suis mort
j'étais pas au courant tu m'as pas de là
il peut forcer les changer d'avis
les corses les changer d'âme dans ces
cas là j'ai plus de temps que lui ok on
attend attendant il faut que nous vite
du coup ouais
on est super nul
près du hat est récupéré du match ça
peut te permettre de faire un échec
intermédiaires ou quoi pour récupérer du
temps le taux de change non mais preuve
c'est qu'en fait je sais pas si on est
mis autant ou pas en fait je ne
comprends rien non il ya une douzaine
d'huîtres
on est mal
je vois aucun nom mais du coup faut
attendre fois tant de fois temps
fait que y avoir l'arrivée de deux dames
d'un coup le problème c'est qu'en fait
qu intermédiaire comme débile non mais
non ça sert à rien un petit des chocs
donc t'es pas c'était pas mal tu en es
en fait non je suis pas m'attendre peut
donner une tour une bonne on m'a dit
vas-y prendre ce que vous êtes pour vous
et carrier en 17 après voyez poser des
ans 17 pour hockey à damerey vas-y fais
ce que tu peux vas-y bateau à fond j'ai
tout blindé comme je pouvais et on va
essayer de se battre mais j'ai pas mal
de l'inde est la plus jouée vite en fait
j'ai tout blindés la faute juste fou
juste pide à fond juste philpot d'hommes
moi j'ai pas d'âme sur l'échiquier de
façon hockey que c'est une cause son
cahier en existe peut-être il peut rien
imposer
le militant photos les plus grand-chose
à poser des non plus mais juste que tu
joue vite hein parce qu'en fait ça va
être affreux twain et moi je suis un peu
de la merde mince massemin si la prime
dame fait des échecs de partout je vais
le faire tomber je fais tomber je fais
ton des femmes ja il tombe vous tombez
des ja bell c'est du grand n'importe
quoi
c'est une purge dans notre niveau la
chômeuse de zermatt où l'on peut poser
sur mars
on cherche un nouvel adversaire fin de
nouveaux adversaires
allez c'est parti alors on joue contre
qui je ne contrôle pas jacobson est un
mec contre toi on joue la française
karine joue peut-être une méthode ruiz
attention
pat a fait une mise à l'horizon il joue
solide a les boules dégage pointage
super bien joué
je vais tout me sacrifier dessus ans à
lui faire très très mal la femme ce 8
août si tu peux me récupère un cavale je
veux vous un deuxième
ouais ça serait fantastique deuxièmement
génial là il en méga pls que je lui
posais un cavale en hausse avec un carré
long f7 ou angers 6 il n'en peut plus ah
non il me donne l'alarmé d'un coup en
fait ils préfèrent donner une dame
n'aurait du ku'damm pour toi alors je
vais poser un cavalli si on va attaquer
sa tour du postdam côté là peut-être
partout tu fait feu de tout bois à
l'essai matteau prochain c'est le leader
ndam de plus vous allez c'est reparti on
est des monstres on défonce ou monde
swatch est semi l'un des gars qui jouent
à 12 de la rue sitôt ruiz aussi
scandinave dans ta gueule dégage
il est quelqu'un qui lui dit mme
attendent un pour fab tard à terme
attendre un tout à l'heure il va vous
remettre quatre éléphants de d2 ouais je
sais pas je ne vois pas la partie on va
pas rare de tomber sur des génies pour
le moment dans le là je ne le suis pas
un du tout tu mérite quand même beaucoup
moins fort aux beats à 4 qu'aux échecs
bah oui mais je n'ai jamais joué à ce
jour ce que ça veut dire plein de gens
qui jouaient dans leur club ou un machin
mais moi non
les gens avaient peur le jeu des gens
avec des amicales de base je connais pas
attention
mince mars mars mars mars mars mars mars
dans la merde et il faut surtout pas de
pions un méchant tendances venaient de
partout je veux me faire ma temps de la
bomba je me parle je veux voir de
l'autre côté je laisse une pièce que si
j'étais bien au fc être le mec mort et
mat et surtout pas dur je suis très très
mal là mais bon je comprends pas comment
joue ton adversaire tu tiens prends le
pion au no faire fuir on est bien au
temps c'est hyper important à dieu mais
ça va ça je le redis j'ai plein des jets
de l'armée l'a foutu ouvre son rock la
infructueux ag londres a adopté les
recettes qu'ils défendent à quelques pas
le truc où des cas pour cheveux en moins
bien un événement là j'ai changé d'âme
je pense que ça en ta faveur
parce que tu es d'annexer une excellente
position à six jeunes hommes buzz la
pause on m7a pas d'où se dégagent au
quai du oui s'est barré avec saddam
bon voilà automatiquement jus prend ses
fonctions
bah c'est fini c'est fini c'est fini on
l'aimé on est bons l'attendre au bol
dans un train plein boom tuba renflouage
[Musique]
alors moi j'ai plein de pions j'sais pas
quoi en faire peur
faisons venus veulent pas je les pose le
plein de ma position et ça me saoule je
défends tout je ne veux plus me faire
attaquer il se passe quoi si je fais
dame ben tu fais juste dames et si tu
manges tu as dame en fait ils enfin
voila il mange un pion en fait
mais regarde ma position et les
fantastiques
j'adore des dons par tous les gens
mettent encore plus en fait j'en ai
marre je crois que je crois que je
m'attelais de poser un architecte et je
mange le seimat j'en ai eu marre mais
des pions partout je ne veux plus qu'on
approche mauroy ça me fatigue j'ai dû
mettre un client des huit aéroports
tu ne t'approche plus je ne veux pas que
tu t'approches debout je n'ai pas que ça
à faire
mais tu peux t'arrêter un mois ils
hématologie d'ailleurs il
il doit abandonner mais bravo bien vrai
ok on joue contre des brésiliens le
terrain les brésiliens issus ou pas le
mien n'ont-ils américains peu de
coalition il ya un marché non non c'est
pas qu'on cache pas c'est surtout le
marché c'est le marché qu'on casse mais
là il m'a pas l'air d'être très bien
gabriel alors attends je reçois un sms
qu'est-ce qui me disent on ne sait pas
assez clash royal un trésor gratuit qui
m'attend est-ce que s'il échange des
dames des machins c'était plaisir en bus
bras et tout me fait plaisir la reine de
masques de pierre centrale
je suis très heureux en fait bout les
gars je t'envoie un pion dans ta gueule
je suis pas vraiment c'est un peu le
bordel il se défend pas mal ils chassent
madame de partout en fait si on regarde
ma position c'est fantastique qui m'a
chassé le guen d'hommes nam a dirigé
l'attaqué
je suis tu as pris en fait suite à pied
avec mes pièces là ok ils chassent bout
je te contre chasse bouturage trois
genres et chat complètement pack de chat
les crimes non je pas y parle entre
australien jeu parce qu'il faut du
concours où m'attend qu'est ce qui fait
souvent mais là son cavalier j'aime pas
du tout ça je dois votre position alors
ok je vais être un pion en 17 jours
mangé avec le plus en fait je vais
blindés être que je peux sacrifice des
trucs où on se foutrait besoin d'un
bolide d'amis de tours en fait des gains
en termes de sacrifices boum puis en 17
matchs moi j'ai un objectif c'est blindé
mon rock et puis après je vais me matter
était bien là tout d'un coup ça plutôt
bien tourné pour nous de manière assez
surprenante
j'ai rien fait pour
moi j'ai en force 1
ok j'ai deux fils et une dame
probablement wind à windham aussi un mec
ne vous tracassez pas mal je vais
évoquer je bouge google s'est pas réjoui
de sa part vers a très bien joué j'ai ma
tendance est ce que je le fais ou pas
question pas d'où ils mènent ma clope
c'est mon ces masses
aïe aïe aïe allez olivier bonnet la
belgique allait bel devenu une doublette
belge
ils ont du mal et bien il faut bosser
les belges ils ont du mal à se connecter
pour le moment tout ce que c'est c'est
leur gros leur grand point difficile
l'olivier qui ce bail se bâfre aller
obama cinq cavaliers avec moi je vous la
théorie il en dire deux parties de suite
le globe variante eric jalton apprend la
théorie moi je la scandinave je vous
emmerde deux bouts vas-y vient manger le
fou on va le maté à l'ancienne
complètement je vais sacrifier le mec
essayé de piéger madame j'aime pas du
tout ça j'aime pas du tout les choses
n'importe quoi je peux poser le pion à
600 était très très bien j'ai fait dit
dieu a posé un pion sur une pièce de
plus normal dès que tu poses sur des
classes normales à ce jeu c'est qu'il
faut pas toujours trop posé sépia c1 par
exemple on adversa il a tout posé et du
coup il a pu rien dans la main rien dans
les mains mais entre les deux surprises
ben ouais mais en fait jusque là il a
beaucoup de pièces et il se bat bien
mais si échange les dames quoi c'est
bien ou c'est débile cité changé d'âme
c'est fantastique pour le ménage sans
guillaume pose un pion de trois jeux
veut sacrifier dessus une position d'
attaques de faux liens
le bâtiment voit le lien l'occasion j'ai
avoir notre château de ce qui se passe
de sucre on peut répondre aux gens un
peu aussi il me chassait qu'un seul à
gagner d'ailleurs il m'a chassée par
tous là c'est horrible il ya tout posez
moi j'ai pas encore mis toutes mes
pièces un un fond la caisse
donc c'est vrai j'ai commencé à
collecter du matos un appui collecter
une pièce beaucoup trop bas ce qui m'a
fait le mec en guest tout ce qui fait un
peu je peux encaisser une tour ma part
et d'autre qui s'échangent de mon côté
ah [ __ ] pas vu ce cavalier de merde là
et chier j'adore ma position fantastique
fond de court qu'est ce qui peut me
poser des pulsions qu'est ce que c'est
que je te fais ça je prends ce que j'en
vois tu veux un quart al
charge de façon très content de ce tome
on fait gaffe quand tu prends des
risques très tactique on est mieux au
temps ou pas
bref pas crime de dames bien sûr et pas
de cours pas de pièces vont pas donnant
rien à temps on a 30 secondes d'avancé
jouer live
il peut que prendre un cavalier donc et
c'est ok city hull
je veux donner n'avons pas nos rêves a
dit c'est pas le top mais bon en fait je
peux aimer je peux lui mais je vais te
donner des cavaliers là tu vas pouvoir
le maté après vas-y prend mais ne
reprend pas à tempo après valois et et
voilà vas-y vas-y manon tu poses non tu
vas rayon cassé des cadres habituels
mater suis pas exactement comment tu vas
faire mais tu vas te débrouilles et ont
jeté en envoie un troisième alors que je
crois qu'il ya matelas et 17 non oui
voilà tu as et ça en fait faut pas faux
pas reprendre tempo les pièces en fait
ça parce que c'est ça en fait
quant à des cta l'initiative tut tut
part en contre attaque
allez on joue contre eux ces exodes lips
the bâton et gibier non c'est un service
à 4
jouer la théorie bâche veut un an mais
je peux t'on échiquier en fait c'est
très agréable
damages who in france s est complètement
je pense que gérard taux est beaucoup
plus fort que toi il fait n'importe qui
est plus fort que moi je n'ai jamais
joué tu commence à sentir un peu le jeu
ou pas du tout encore un bail est donné
mais je me sentirai jamais fut réticents
aux athées réticents c'est la première
personne que je fais est réticente à ce
jeu c'est un des jeux les plus marrants
fait face et des vrais échecs pour te
goût des cases avec ton cavaliers
là c'est très très bien là pour le
moment où tout est cavalier de partout
je le fais reprises en passant je n'ai
pas la france assume la bombe écoute si
la perceuse culture et ouais on va faire
des visas cas toute la soirée
alors je pose un carrier angers 2
je ne sais pas je ne sais pas je ne sais
pas j'ai dit djezzy femme aussi ce que
tu as un cavalier pour moi mais là je
suis en train de charrier lui faire une
prise à deux là j'ai mille cavaliers à
eux deux qui me permet de boue 30 sur
échec mais il peut en fait y'a pas mal
ce qui peut couvrir style ce que j'ai
dit ça va être hyper dangereuse qui est
en train de faire est ce que tu peux me
passer un cavale éventuellement ce bon
il va y arriver a dit prendre acte de
cession alors attends tu vas passer un
fou pour le moment mais je vois pas de
risque et ça m'énerve beaucoup je
comprends pas ça change tout le temps de
jeu je vois pas les pendre votre
adversaire joue à rien ce jeu peut plus
gérer ils sont bien autant ils sont tous
mieux ils sont assez bien pour savoir ça
me fait chier de pas répondu c'est hyper
désagréable que je comprends pas le jeu
comme on en voit que les banques c'est
un bug
bah ouais mais bon je joue pas du coup
est ce qu'on fait le beau jeu que ce que
tu veux tant pis pas de beau jeu genève
les sacs c'est une dame est un peu tout
mais bon
ta position est fantastique c'est génial
tu te bats fond je défends quoi était
tapi dans l'ombre aux besoins latapie qu
est ce chou il me plaît pas du tout doit
être en train de autant on est en train
de faire l'effort là qui est ce qui fait
qu'elle est géniale la pression mais il
ne peut pas approcher ton roi est trop
de pions
le truc est complètement entouré de
pions en fait c'est génial fantastique
ta voisine et might & magic en fait donc
les menaces partir en sucette surprendre
saddam non ouais je prends les miennes
on s'en fout ouais ça va aller c'est que
ça il veut me pose un truc arrive de
jeumont très droit et kg 3 ok donc je
veux prendre du fou et je vais faire en
f1 obligé
mks et l'a obligé bon alors attend
peut-être que tu vas pouvoir ne plus
jouer et je gardais une seconde mais je
suis pas encore mode du tout non mais
sarah joujou encore mais ils sont en
train de dangereusement tombé à
dieulefit l'epad dames le corps est
comme ça donne tout retrait après manger
trois sinon faudrait juste réussir à
monter c'est que ce coup de main j'étais
avec mon roi il à propos d'un footing
j'en ai rien à [ __ ]
merde j'en ai parlé il ya une bonne case
de disparaître c'est pas parce que tu as
plus de temps que lui maintenant tu vas
pouvoir attendre attends attends ne
jouent pas ne jouent pas ne joue pas
achevé de verdun prend bat à sept
secondes de plus peut-être que moi je le
mat le guen effet d'un proche ou pas m
et je réponds mais ça lui donne une dame
pour défendre un look emo tunis je te
dis moi je suis autant enfin atemi
autant que lui et je pense qu'il est mat
imparable et peu comme faire un ou deux
échecs ou vont il m'a fait un échec
ok il peut me faire un deuxième échec de
seconde veut jouer au petit jeu c'est
bon c'était chaud ouais à tant de zones
je peux quitter revenir comme ça
peut-être que ça va enlever le bloc de
merde de pearl jeu et georgie sur
accueil et je me bats route est toujours
là en fait toujours attendre du goût est
ce qu'on est encore ensemble ou pas les
yeux rouges contre les mêmes
ouais ok je revois le chantier juste
retrait et certains des meilleurs
joueurs de busacca du truc et 2007 sans
vis à 400 sont bien putté un nouveau bug
bouh le pion à 6 dégage très très
tactique m'appartient je la grèce un peu
prend le fou prend le fou pour le vous
voyez vas-y vas-y cette fantastique
vous êtes un cadeau d'une tour la suite
tu vas voir une tour là qui va arriver
je pense un peu de servir qu'aux
tranchantes
ouais éventuellement si tu m'envoies un
méchant c'est génial je prends en
vigueur ce que tu peux prendre des 4
fantastiques
ce graphique pour giggs va faire dans le
fait qu as quand même
mais oui tu peux sacrifier mais fais
gaffe de pas de faire maths et 6 passes
dont je ferai en sorte que nos petiots
ouais ça mais est ce que tu te fais
maths et si j'avais un pion ce que tu
utilisais été donnée un pion en fait tu
ne me donnes papillon points ne peut
plus on donne un papillon je me casse
mais très plaisir en attendant le faire
craquer qui drive 100 kg 5 et qui
traînent dans les rues sauf une merde
tahiti maintient ses 5
mais bon là je me cassais je suis assez
mal quand même merde je vais me matter
of life est malin et fantastique
les pauvres eux mêmes ont été beaucoup
envie autant mais on est perdu abandon
vous fait n'importe quoi en fait un
super match joué face est mal conseillé
alors bien sûr on repart pour une partie
d'ailleurs je compte des italiens [ __ ]
je vois pas les chics et ça me saoule
que j'avais d'abandonner quoi ça peut
jouer puis ça s'est très mal très mal
maintenant ici au québec la suisse passe
à côté de tels peut-être fait juste un
refresh en fait bon se pardonne je
raccroche et donc rafraîchir ça marche
mieux en tant qu'etat est toujours et
toujours une solution
du coup même en fait je vous la théorie
enfin je m'en fous complètement
la théorie normal des échecs les faux
échec en fait
mais qui joue des francesca une fin je
suis pas française lance pas top mais
c'est vrai que joue pas avec ses 5 du
coup ça va peut-être
alors allez hop
oh non je viens de faire la grosse daube
là pourquoi pareil cas et prendre les
quatre hommes je donne la dame
le beau jeu non mais s'il faut jouer le
beau jeu femmes
bon il fait beau je te veux non en fait
la dame s'est pas si forts à ce jeu vaut
le savoir qu'est ce qui vous prend ses
sets ça embête un peu je peux changer de
nom n'échange pas n'échange pas les bons
intérims en face de moi si je suis
d'ailleurs je me fais du bon roi qu'est
ce que je fais là on va perdre nouveau
raid de nouveau perdre en fait
absolument neuf je dois attendre
je sais que je joue pas vous poser un
pur angers 4,7 g
[Musique]
bahreïn est bon quand tu fais le beau
jeu c'est difficile on ne fait pas le
jeu en fait non c'est trop con tu as
droit faiblesse pour se marrer aussi aux
parades averti que sous gestion que je
peux je faire le beau jeu kingdom
biotech dans la tronche je sais pas
comment je ne pas me faire mater on va
essayer
c'est une boucherie ce truc là alors
c'est un peu déconcentré là après nos
victoires c'est trop facile mais j'ai
devant moi je joue très très bien enfin
gers est pas un mystère
je comprends pas enfin fait j'aime pas
je ne contrôle pas le jour il m'arrive
des pièces que chez paul sort c'est
chiant j'aime pas s'en vont j'aime me
comprendre ce qui se passe vous pire le
bug house à deux c'est ce que je donne
je ce qui se passe mais note émise par
un tiers le crédit house exactement
banjo kazooie patron jouant vite pour
moi ils menacent des maths en dessin
quand ils menacent un tas de trucs pour
se voir invités j'ai bien jusqu'où ça
c'est un gros carnage bon alors on
essaye de le matin je suis pas comment
mais un truc je me bats comment je peux
pas vous fier je tiens comment est ce
qu'on sait tous que je tiens ce que je
peux porter vu que je ne sais pas
comment mais je tiens çi nerfs je suis
mat
marié reparti
mallet faut qu'on se ressaisisse
j'ai hyper chaud deux ongles vernis
faire le beau jonathan
allez hop sa partie alors je me cachais
tout parce que les jets une attaque de
fraude peut accepter les frelons
asiatiques bausch colons ont froid coup
flotte francofans jeu est beaucoup moins
violent acheminer d'horizons bien la
métallerie et n'autorise un autre où je
t'ai fait j'ai si je te pose un pion h61
g7 du cou ou métaux druze du tueur fut
champion l'heure tu es dans le turf eu
le vaisseau mère fantastique savoir
mieux qu'une vraie mais tabriz en fait
tu poses tout ce qui se fait ou ce qu'il
faut donc les gens tout cas ils nous ont
confié jour en l'aspirine quoi avec
blocage anti jo me lucien je suis
vraiment nul à ce jeu mauricie a quand
même fait un des pions test déteste
quand ils font ça ok tu ne joues plus
ton je peux plus tu veux un pion
pourquoi la en fête propose un pion c6
messieurs faire un blocus n'est là que
pour ça je fais n'importe quoi alors en
revanche ils sont mieux au temps mais
ils n'ont pas l'air d'attendre qu'on
s'en fiche un fou sa tête ou pas non
jouions regard juste sur le faisant
c'est sarah maintient le fuyard le sait
très bien
donc le choix
[Musique]
écrite mais je veux si tu vas faire quoi
en fait qu'on va je bosse à rien quoi
qu'est ce que c'est que ça bon zoom et
autorise que je ne m'intéresse pas de
jouer à ce jeu je me donnerais beaucoup
de temps fou à le mec torse à la fin il
est insupportable
ça ne fait pas du tout à l'attaqué ont
fait absolument on est absolument nul
c'est horrible c'est affreux je suis
très très content de me donne rien mais
en fait tu en viens pas de cavalier
temps qu'il ya pas de truc qui arrive ça
va pour toi je lis ça je dis rien si on
donne une dame il peut être mat
ça me paraît pas évident allez dégagez
dégagez pièce bout le pion mais qui de
se dire qu'est ce que c'est que ce genre
en deux ans je n'ai pas dépassé la
cinquième en géant
est ce que c'est vraiment un grand
maître ou est ce que c'est un idiot fini
qui se fait passer pour un grand match
je pense je suis à nous mais c'est hyper
celui de la défense ainsi que j'adore ta
position
je pense que c'est la quintessence même
du jeu en fait la position c'est l'âme
de drize exemple on a gagné par abandon
eyes on pouvait plus mais il a vu de la
solidité du passé j'ai vu que enlevés
tôt de rudy tout de suite elle était
géniale ta partie a été fantastique
ok gphone méthodes russes d'irak b3 ou
non les mecs ont abandonné avant même le
plan de m
fantastique l'agd veulent même plus chez
les ifi oy de maple arbitres l'a
peut-être je sais pas d'où ma méthode
ruiz
il ya une vraie méthode risque est ce
que ça trois jeunes loups hic c'est que
ce bordel bontoux bugs après on a écrit
par abandon à les précédents oui mais
pas contre la la on vous l'a c'est
l'empathie zappé toutes les fenêtres
tout seul il fait n'importe quoi obtenir
4 qu'est-ce qui fait il contre-attaqué à
taux de rythme avec niveau mais 7 fief
de 33.3 commence tu t'en fiches si
sacrifice ce qui m'a déjà sacrifié en
fait donc du coup ils peuvent pas
sacrifier à deux c'est un truc important
à je sais qu'il y en a un des deux qui
sacrifie et que l'autre sacrifier aussi
du coup plus personne n'a de pièces en
fait c'est pas du tout comme le crazy
house bon là du coup il est très très
mal le mec le tient je pense qu'il faut
il accuser quiconque en fout quoi il
faut que tu évites de donner un pion si
possible j'ai tout partout non mais bon
c'est pas mal du coup c'est pas être
trop grave
en plus on est très bien autant
6 il veut un pion je laisse pendre bah
si tu le prends comme ça je peux poser
un pion ça m'arrange
si c'est toi qui peint aux mouches
comment je change de domme ça va dépoter
contente si je changerais méga fan quand
même pas changer tout ça ou la diagonale
pour une élection gsm
il n'en peut plus these que je te prends
moi je suis solide suis solide ça va
changer d'un coup au travers de neuf
donc je filerai plus un fou à ta place
ce serait bien si je vais créer une
contre attaque en fait mais je ne veux
pas attaquer je suis en méthode rose à
la main ce n'est absolument pas mon
objectif
ça vient de ruiz eefje la position genre
de remettre tous les pions sur la 7e
c'est bon un petit coup des chefs en
revanche moi je peux échanger les dames
toi tu t'en fiches complètement
j'imagine patoisant ruiz collation était
très heureux en fait alors ils menacent
mon pions qu'est ce qui me fait le
sacrifice ou d'éveil changer les dames
elles changé les dames ce serait
fantastique demain jour auquel je me
revois le vrai mais si tu es du site
échange des amis les maths ça peut être
assez disqualifiant pour rené changé
d'âme et on ait mis autant du qui ne
plus surtout pas prendre ta dam là et tu
menaces de pause est à l'amendé 8 pour
échanger les dames c'est à ce point
important de changer baala il est ma
tendre ainsi des dangers l'âme donc
automatiquement
on est très très bien les gens les dames
bon ben vous bouffe sa love chose que je
peux faire échec mais je pose en ce 8 11
vous pouvez y prennent goût ils peuvent
plus rien faire dix secondes de plus
dans leurs écrits dans le chat il ou le
chat de la partie boostée à l'aise quand
même que c'est pas mal hein tout d'un
coup ils sont dits qu'ils attaquaient
par fulham et aduriz a encore frappé je
veux le chat audio ce qui se passe et se
passe absolument rien les gens sont
mécontents
non ils ont pris le contrôle sur son
site complètement ils sont même pas
venus en fait on fera peut-être une
petite session pour le spécial les 5000
abonnés pour un screen en poste 2104 bon
ben je voulais y aura plus de monde
puisque on sera sur youtube pour voir ce
que les gens pensent et on discute avec
bon autorise de nouveau la chance que tu
vas écoeuré les gens ils vont et écuries
nous comme les réserves au poids
j'ai refait ford à 6,10 à poire bon
maryse on revient des pions la retraite
partout où je serai très content
le coquil afin de comprendre un câble et
ouais je suis très heureux d'un cavalier
fait tous les cas y ait eu un même deux
je suis toujours surprise qu'on obtient
volée je suis heureux des pions je suis
heureux de tous là la voiture est sur
eux ne met que mes goûts malgré son nom
de saison rue allent et boum
il est temps de changer un peu des
pièces pas trop quand même
bon écoute genre est parti avec mon
romieu l'échiquier mais change pas les
dames
et puis je m'en fous qui approcheront 3
me cacher mais ne joue ben en fait on va
souvent inconscient mais c'est bien les
mecs firme vient de prendre des pièces
non c'était pas validé elle mange pas
les cacher c'est un peu un pion je m'en
fous à lier
[Musique]
en fait paris face au lift y est à ruiz
en fait je bouge aussi soit je suis très
content
il est collé mais des gens de partout
c'est ça l'essentiel de ses envies je
fais roi c8 et c'est pas grave si le
côté bon ben j'ai pas le choix il faut
que tu ailles ans et 8 mai à madame v n
va ne sapent nos fans et même à des deux
côtés à y aller on se fait défoncer par
tout le monde c'est une horreur et si
cela n'arrive pas vraiment à jouer
solide et un jeu lorsque les gens disent
notre dernière vidéo sur un franc le
truc c'est amer dans hard on parle de
regarder ce que les gens bas je prends
maintenant je vais voir ce que les gens
disaient de notre dernière vidéo sur moi
ou déjà 58 like temps mais qui me parle
de l'attak baudelaire chez même pas ce
que c'était que charles bohler bao de
leurs variantes de la sicilienne les
mecs pensent qu'on connaît en fait c'est
votre combat qu'est ce que c'est que ça
mais goût de tous
c'est le bordel cette partie j'ai peur
de me faire attaquer partout la attaques
de baudelaire de baudelaire de baba
omrou
enfin je sais pas c'est vendre les
siennes c'est quoi les coups de son
ballon il me dit ma du mais qu'en même
temps le nom de l'ex c'est pas le plus
important
bon alors tu as besoin de quoi
absolument un jean fou je sais tu
arrives pour attaquer c'est horrible je
veux pas te casse moteur
c'est affreux met en avant tu défends
bien tu es là bah écoute ses mégots
sacrifier pour ses pièces me rend fou
120 cavaliers ce tu commences à contre
attaquer c'est cool ça m'aide le cas
rennais battu me plierai un pion ça
peut-être fini la partie j'aurais mis un
pied en judo depuis mille ans mais ça
aurait demandé d'attaquer c'est pas dans
l'esprit on sait à domec a compris
comment jouer mon adversaire il concerne
poser des pions partout jana
extraordinaire mais là il a il a pas mal
de pièces qui sont arrivés mais toi
aussi me to alors ce que tu as
éventuellement moyen du chopper un
cavale banon la mine aurait posé n'est
pas se trace sur l'échiquier du coup moi
je me risque à redeyef si ce matin mais
vous bah oui mais c'est la base on ne
pouvait pas jouer mais tu m'as dit
fallait que j'attaque je suis parti en
attaque
la belge a pas bougé une oreille que
jamais une unité la koala une histoire
si tu mates j'ai pas de pièces h4 le
plus grand flou
merde j'échange tokyo ifa
contre-attaqué la dame dégage bon mais
ne donne pas matérielle en fait je suis
très bien j'arrive s'ils attaquent très
facilement mais s'il me remets une vague
de pièces ça peut me plaire au maire
d'une vague de pièces qui arrivent
c'était tout je suis se trouve ça aïe
aïe aïe mais je pousse f5 sectionné un
décor très bientôt tu vas pouvoir
arrêter de jouer mais on s'en fout tu
aurais vu qu'aux dépens de matt bobo
temps que moi je suis pas mat ce bon ben
ouais mon gérant quand t'arrêtes de jury
comprennent que namco en prend lui
saddam à la levée que j'ouvrais échec
mais il a du mal en faute et c'est un
peu plus dur pour lui d' art qu'est ce
que ça allait mais que les charlottes là
ils vont abandonner pas ils ont encore
plus compris
c'est génial ce fantastique moi je
prenne où je m'en fous j'adore vos
vidéos une dispute ou 201 ils comptent
leurs six pur faut partager de partout
ou spirou tu partages tout le temps
partout et tout le temps là en fait j'en
ai marre de ces sacrifices en effet
cette ça me saoule hâte aussi agent peu
plus long que je peins non on ne
téléphone
attends je faisais un pion f6 je ne veux
pas avoir de cavaillon g500 rétro soul
et cali angers 5 et essayent d'éviter
l'échangé car il est quand même ça ça me
fait donc j'ai changé qu'elle est
directe due à dix huitième de le faire
chez rim
quelle merde j'en ai marre de sacrifices
en excès de fougue les évite
j'en ai marre je vais je vais ruiz y
fier aussi quoi marc barrât [ __ ] de
claque la double temps fou mais je pense
c'est dans l'esprit allez dégage du coup
je jouais solide à mon tour je vais très
content une excuse pour jouer solide
ouais ouais c'est clair mais ce que tu
donnes windham enfin si j'ai filé une
dame et prennent sais que je peux même
pas sur les bons cavaliers en fait je
reste dans la merde malgré la dame filet
en fait bon tenez bon écoute mais
comment comment on fait pour réussir à
toujours se faire agresser je vais grand
roque et j'en ai marre mais moi je vais
me faire arrêter quand même en fait
point puisque s'excuse merde mieux
sacrifier mais je m'en fout de ton
sacrifice
alors on se fait on se fait laminer quoi
c'est horrible on est absolument nous je
fais chaque déjà je pêchais pas le mec
force de moi c'est un [ __ ] c'est
horrible je me faire mater comme une
merde je reviens avec mon cavalier quoi
à tous les espoirs reposent sur toile un
hockey très content ou encore imposer
des trucs quand j'en ai marre allez hop
dégage mais c'est pas grave
son sacrifice huit ans fou bachelot dont
le mien en revanche les redoutables gc
ca ah non merde et maintenant vous voyez
super match balma la base il avait pas
ce qu'ils ont bruissé softphone de jeu
c'était un truc qui arrive peu prévu
mais on vous pas assez offensif faut
qu'on attaque plus d'un mois je m'adapte
à jamais interdit je m'en fou balle et
moi j'ai sacrifié avec 7 ça m'a saoulé
ils ont trop ça que fut un f-16 j'en ai
marre ok on a tous les deux d'aller boom
par non ils m'empêchent d'attaqué c'est
pas possible
ouais tu voues la théorie là tu très
très bien mettons cauquil o tac et un
baril qui commet un crime puni
ok je suis prêt à faire c'est à faire
tout péter là j'en ai marre avec ma tach
me donne pas de pions papillon back four
j'oublie je veux juste qu'on vous vite
en fait attend les malades va être
dégoûté en fait des études en a rien à
[ __ ] des coups normaux et noir il veut
juste un tour ce qu'on arrive à nous
d'être ans et cette même nom ok mais on
va être mis autant là on ait mis autant
maintenant vertu des nouveaux lequel
valley on y va voir son pion demeure me
fait très clair d'ivoire sans tuer il va
me faire quatre fichiers [ __ ] j'ai
oublié ça il a fait recaler pro f de ces
horribles j'aurais dû attendre au casino
bio c'est bon tu peux juste que tu veux
donner mais qu'on craque et un poil trop
tôt beaucoup sur ok jeunesse v6
je pense que finn dames c'est pas mal ça
me file un pion qui dégage
et quand on fait pour te voir les
positions des poubelles en fait ben je
sais pas j'ai aucun athlète ce je ne
sais pas bonjour avant que dire de cinq
minutes pour guy a fait nul
bassila ratait est avec vous et cette
fille squatteront deep il coiffe est une
pièce après ok si à cinquante pièces qui
tombent dans les mains faire un truc
humaine ça ne ressemble à rien c'est
juste une pièce elle est bon il en soit
et sexy c'est que patron c'est de la
merde qu'est ce que tu joues pas tu peux
te le dire c'est mauvais pour une fois
c'est moi qui reste à être en attaque
pas vraiment attaqué aussi fortement que
je voudrais la fab
je vais gagner une pièce est une tour
mais je suis pas si sa prime c'est qu'il
va attaquer que ces cavaliers de partout
après joseph grande je réussisse à
l'attaqué là
la [ __ ] mais ils ont grimpé au nord
qui arrive moitié
puis de films de séries galles oui c'est
grave
toujours dame ouais pas me défendre
on n'est pas bien tu peux prendre ça un
tour c'est pas trop grave
non mais le problème c'est qu'il a des
pièces par tous pour vos tags de fois
j'ai senti un clavier qui peut arriver
dans le set partout le pape pour moi je
change et ça fait la dame veut parce que
je joue au hockey les pistes tout le
temps on coche
des pièces qui arrivent dans son tableau
quoi c'est juste qu'on est frais très
nul en fait preuve c'est que moi je
n'attaque pas du tout son roi et en fait
on sait tout en attaque et c'est
horrible on est tout le temps sous
pression en fait moi aussi je me fais
attaquer comme une merde et maisons sont
faits rien ne change pas de pièces et
les autres on joue juste deux échecs
sont les meilleurs ouais mais tu ne peux
pas faire ça
beaucoup meilleur jeu qu'au prix d'un
goûter
ne donne rien on émeutes faisant 1,3
posant l'oeuvre sur lequel cage volonté
savage charlie maitien clous et
croisillons perez mex il abat secondes
donc toi tu as survécu mais moi je ne
survivrais pas en fait il ya trop de
pièces et c'est mon roi qui a attaqué je
ne peux rien faire seul truc c'est as tu
peux le faire tomber
tu peux le dire tu peux le battre au
vrai échec là à temps mais là tu peux le
mat et à 40 caisses de plus il faut
juste que tu mal vite
[ __ ] mais dans merde au nom enfin ces
moissons geagea jeunes et ben tiens si
tu avais un je peux te prendre un pion à
donner pour finir je veux prendre un
pied il tombait plutôt rond ben c'est ça
qu'il faut faire en fait faut réussir à
jouer au vrai échec à la fin en fait je
ne connais pas vous c'est fantastique
grand dessein répondait ça je vous
souhaite à tous dans la merde rien
d'autre ok mais la conche veut confirmer
femme sait je suis mort mais fait aussi
ce fait si ce système est bon et qui se
font à 5
elle est très très bien maintenant ça
rime foot - tu déjà plus à m'en voudrais
tout et tu peux la sacrifier davantage
les choses d'un procès 3 blu-ray par un
moment j'ai la perdre ce sont ses écrits
mais ça c'est génial que j'ai changé que
tu m'aies récupère un fantastique si je
peux me récupère encore un cavale alors
c'est ça la chose au dessus donc que
notre poitrine est un bon jeu je veux
donc maintenant balao prochain prochain
donc il aida temps mais bon en matinée
sont évoqués niveau des gages cud cavale
c'est génial
les royals j'en tirerai inquiète même
bout et 40 de parts ou un non ou encore
je vais défiler une dame je pense moi
aussi quand je vois les uns servent
alors à temps pour le mans il défend un
fou et c'est matt ont joué c'est votre
nom ne veut pas qu'on joue sur soi mais
une dame et ses matières nobles et sont
placés au pied je me s'échangent des
damned ils sont mal
j'attends un peu pour le moment mais ce
qu'on peut
crise ou pas de retours de dalmat et
deux pions et c-max de bios autres non
non non non non non grosses conneries
joignent à une grosse connerie ça s'est
passé n'est juste pas de tout repos dame
un deuxième qui ont quand même eu droit
tout un wave asie prendre et s'arrêtent
matelas pascale clavel si ça te dirait
[Musique]
maintenant quand même non je fonde
berkman
on est complètement nul allez moi je
refais une scandinave parce qu'on a vu
avec six points parce qu'on en avait que
si c'est très très bien
tu peux te faire enfermer la dame est en
fait c'est pas grave parce que je sais
des buts à 4 c'est très très bien
ok j'ai compris on est complètement
nulle azur en fait moi je n'ai pas trop
de doutes tu remets toi 200% boîte en
asie où les gages normand fait toi tu es
très très nul mois déjà mauvais mais zot
est encore un reçu pour les cacher tout
ce qui m'amène des trucs ou paul se
moque attaque lapointe photo mj tit re
jeu comme initiative et att pièces qui
arrivent dans la sur la gueule très
fréquentes impute la tête partout la
meca des pions cochon mamba baribeau
cause et d'où sortait pion aux [ __ ]
mais bon écouter la lecture et
l'adoption n'est pas grave
voilà c'est alors c'est le moule quoi je
suis rentré le boulier j'avais un effort
collectif avec mais les pièces qu'elles
agissent avec l'option m6
ils seront la paix se battent à plein
coup de fourchette
[Musique]
mais tu imagines tiens qu'est ce que
l'on fait mais suppose un fou dans les
services les matchs se faisait en
fourrant g7 en fait tu vas menacée est
dur à défendre qu'à radio ici mais qui
oblige nos temps forts tous les tours h8
un cavalier amateur ou zemmour à 8 g7
qu'ils allaient h6 en force
on rejoue batman c'est moi batman batman
sicilienne grosse haut niveau
voici ce qui comprend mieux le double
les pions quoique c'est logique
stratégique des blancs mais déjà rouge
aux échecs en armes apporte quoi bon bah
je rentre à la maison
il est bien ce partout la thur
voilà un truc c'est à windham dégénère
dans tous les sens tuture veut la donne
pas non à jour activités changer ce que
les mecs attaque fortement bon ben je
peux mettre en position foetus quoi je
défends mais je vais peut-être me faire
matin en fait avec attac fortement là
j'espérais que ça bon
quelque part j'arrive avec mes deux cas
cela je joue un peu vite mais je ne
comprends pas les mecs encore un
cavalier [ __ ] c'est vrai on s'en fout
c'est pas faux que tu mates
ok je veux contre attaques à bagdad ont
fait des trucs quoi limo qui ont là où
je veux fait attaqué de toutes parts
j'en peux plus mais le mec de tromper
les soins il se prend il se prend la
marée noire et blanche pas moi là il a
un matin si le vois je pense que faire
fois en huit mois il n'a pas vu mais
tu arrives pas le maté pour le moment 5e
faire mettre en premier c'est horrible
ilham aliev a imposé sa pièce takahata
gagnant car elle un nom mais bon ok
enfin tu as gagné car est pas du tout
bacharach d'un canal eu très très mal
je suis obligé de sacrifier je vais
avoir une dame qui va arriver mais bon
pas le choix j'avais tient le coup de
genou on peut pas
brême en fait c'est que
seiichi mal mais bon toi tu es mieux je
pense tu vas faire dame des six échecs
ou des trucs comme ça sur veut pas
j'arrive à ok ils vont va mettre un
petit chien deuxième dame de rigueur
j'ai pas le choix
ensuite on va changer de boulot avec à
savon il n'a pas échangé mais regrette
d'avoir bon sont floues venir je peux
par image et faire maths et là je peux
le mépriser peut-être je le méprise je
me résous pas mais je suis mal dans tous
les cas qui est dame ou pas c'est fini
murdoch
c'est une purge en est hyper nul c'est
horrible
on est mort on est super nul
en fait les deux dernières à autres
s'arrêtent pas comprendre pourquoi on
n'arrive jamais attaqué cci you je
pensais dans les ouvertures qu'on fait
n'importe quoi
j'arrive pas à les attaquer ça me saoule
bien ensemble je suis en train de
défendre c'est horrible
et c'est reparti le mec va meurent
sacrifier ça dans la gueule et ça est
reparti du haras on est tout le temps en
défense tout le temps ben ouais ça on
peut sans dépenser plus très concret je
suis pas très content un papillon pas si
mr jacques hebinger fils adam aussi vous
c'est mafiosi film est un pion aux
prises en plus ok mais si tu veux passer
bond à 10 secondes d'avancé h pas bien
bien mais bon moi je survis fait
offrande sso prochain qui va très
content du le médiator en fatigue
comprends pas qu'ils valent autant dans
ses bons jours un coup non c'est un pion
nous posons cette e-menace dam des
vitres cassées lors un peu une pause aux
5 assez bon le jeter en fait je pensais
leur art pourquoi pas je sais pas j'ai
pas la dame dans le monde
d'ailleurs je la donne et madame
complètement
on va on va faire ça on va défendre
tranquille prend un cavalier pour un
cavalier par toi et prend un cavalier
jeux pour lesquels preuve qu'elle dégage
je me rends position tout le monde
défend quoi voir un peu de matériel
quand même en face quand même d'une
build à une tour un fou mais ok mais bon
là il faut pas t'as pas vraiment attaqué
je pense non mais que sa mère dit après
un cavalier on va je suis mat 1 à y
apposer une dame d'une tour il a toutes
les pièces qualify surtout pas des
cavaliers mais bon j'avais pas vu on est
complètement nulle quoi en fait on
communique pas assez jeu contre attaque
va ou pas moi je sais pas comment barre
et je vais me faire mater de façon c'est
sûr ok maintenant mais peut-être qu'on a
vu autant takam une dizaine de secondes
avant son caméraman quelque chose
continue non mais la prochaine fois vous
communique plus mais qui y consacrant ps
il s'écrit tout partout n'importe
comment
j'essaye de jouer un peu sans tomber et
puis après on pouvait finir
le truc c'est qu'en fait moi je vais me
faire mater en gros ok mais joli et
sinon on arrête de jeu mais sait on a
beau on a beaucoup de temps d'avant
centre à deux c'est très très bien pas
besoin
il faut juste ou pas en fait c'est bon
je vais gagner tout seul en légale des
gros jennir on a acheté le jeu
où ces deux astres en grèce et qui lit
ma voix la dernière mais en fait c'est
sympa de truc c'est que moi je fais un
peu n'importe quoi
touchstone position foetale bogeys aux
fenêtres
collectivement il soit en position
foetale la dernière admet ces salles qui
décide toi c'est ce qui montre à part
entière comme nuls quoi bouder gages à
l'évêque de jouer hk très rapidement
changé a tout compris il me fait une
espèce de raptor en fait moi aussi moi
brise
bon je vais défense de merde mais déjà
des cas litigieux jam attaquer mais je
savais faire fondre avec des composants
des trois marins contre cavaliers là bon
à part ça tout à fait normal c'est
content que ce que je faisais des pièces
le souffle ainsi que j'adore quand il
joue un peu normal ok je leur tends
pions bien quelque part pour moi non pas
je porte pas pour le moment non
grand chose tu en baisse est dans sa
gueule quoi je les bats il va tout mais
là c'est autre chose des quatre nages
aux young boys boit je vous déclare tu
t'opposes un pion à 6 en fait il ya deux
ans je n'ai rien imposé
c'est aussi ça du coup je vis temps avec
eux c'est notre seule stratégie et je
travaille un peu de matériel
pas tellement
donc officiellement on est complètement
nul à ce jeu là c'est officiel chance de
gagner le tour c'est que j'ai plein de
ses bras qui me fais attaquer je ne
comprends pas tu me fais tout le temps
attaqué j'en ai marre autre exemple un
truc c'est qu'on réussit jamais à faire
des attaques de ma classe je revis qui
sont en train de menacer des matches ça
le mec qui va venu il va venir sacrifier
ces mères ville va reposer sur fer
qu'elle prend 17 morts auxquels il a
plein à prendre chez moi plus que
j'aimerais tant et si bien que je
n'échangerais ben moi j'ai je vais
essayer d'aller mater j'en ai marre le
mec non non non non mais ne va rien
faire juste si nos tomates peur c'est
très bien mais je vais aller nous
arriver que je veux aller le maté en
fait j'en ai marre j'en ai marre jeu
d'échecs normaux je suis pas content
j'en ai marre de me faire attaquer ça me
saoule au quai avant de détruire à parce
que ça comme ça en fait là il comme moi
il a plus rien d'isoler le film plus
rien on veut être le mec en place
moi je n'ai qu'un objectif aller le
matin fait j'en ai carrément si tu
penses du procès de il est très mal un
peu de chemin mais j'en ai plus rien
foutu veulent mater ça ne m'interesse le
reste ne m'intéresse plus
dégage j'ai très envie de sacrifier
madame banon
non mais vous pouvez être normal ça j'ai
très envie de cinq films dame pour te
mettre en pls et non de tous a critical
rien à faire allez hop
doit-on défense
est-ce que j'ai trois que sert à rien
mais du coup j'ai compris que je dois
défendre [ __ ] non mais pourra-t-on ces
deux mais non mais ça va bloquer mais
demain pions le massacre est qu'un pion
et les pions bessette qui ne bougent
plus quoi mais bon si j'ai pas les pieds
ce qu'il faut je pourrais me pose un
deuxième tube et de quoi boucher qui
suppose un plan b 2 les procès de [ __ ]
les gars des kuchis une dame konan
génial on a gagné je me trouve on a
gagné là je veux être c'est pourquoi il
était de nouveau complètement raide
civile
après ils ont abandonné justement va
m'écouter et émeutes ont fait la berd et
veut aller là les invertis décide tout
j'ai tout sacrifié toute première fois
un mec est un juge une vraie partie bah
non je suis un studio en 1/2 veut savoir
où on va faire une vraie partie pour
finir mais on fait une répartie dans
l'esprit du vide ça craint que j'avais
sacrifier un truc que je ne comprends
pas je ne comprends pas le jeu auquel je
suis content je dois regarder fargo
maintenant
[Musique]
nouveau maraîcher n'importe quoi donc
c'est la der des der c'est une vraie
partie mais très ici de jouer au vrai
échec une fois qu'on a qu'on a fait le
vide ça quatre ans tripple chedjou et
déjà parier bitstream web estime et la
tendresse schumann je peux quand même
joué dans l'esprit de huit à six hommes
pour mettre en place ouais
ouais je sais pas bon voilà l'occasion
ce truc mais bon en fait de vol c'est
qu'on joue mal et puis en plus on parle
pas avec le chat quoi n'y avait pas de
chat en soit 101 et 50 personnes qu'on
va notre cours de l'audience gens n'ont
pas aimé le beats à 4 mai dernier nous a
dit si si si il faut face mairie c'est
très très bien réparé par des chèques
aux vidéos vous fait 15 vidéos par
semaine mais non moi je sais pas mais là
en fait les mecs un peu en pls en fait
les ressacs fils adam où tu ne la font
pas que non mais je fais ce que je veux
faire c'est 1 0 non je ne veux pas
prendre à la ça ne m'intéresse pas de
l'x d'une pièce faible beats hockey
garde ta dam je t'emmerde
les dix juges comprends pas j'ai pas de
piste sa cause mais attend
et puis ces trois cas le dock et je dois
dire ouais je vais causer des trucs par
le roi mais je veux dans l'esprit 804
8005 à se faire car heddaf qu'as-tu
désolé je ramène des pièces d'or le roi
j'ai envie de mater la dame ce n'est pas
une pièce assez forte pour perdre du
temps pour nous
boom dans l'esprit ça c'est de l'esprit
du mythe sakata fonda c'est bien ça mais
quelle surprise
imprenable qu'est ce qu'un problème si
ça se dégage ok on s'en fout mais
fawcett nous un peu plus qu'on n'allait
tour un way n'a su à fond dans l'esprit
la tour berlin existe délicate ouais
mais bon je vois dans le genre indien
qui ferait de nombreux indices il faut
creuser ces propositions auxquelles de
ce nom maintenant je sais enfin paris sg
4e rang à chis fait du valais le matelas
non je dis juste up mais les notes
horloge qui est des bons centres où je
vais jouer à fond dans l'esprit bout le
cavaly qui va revenir vers f5 le très
sérieux c'est parti je me c'est très
belle partie en fait là c'est ça ça ça
que sert le beats a cassé pour série
three kivu après je relativise de leurs
des pièces bientôt tu vas arriver
le major et que les qualités je me suis
vraiment les gens quel sens y en a 5 et
puis maintenant vous passez des heures
salle daniel wass qui fait l'appel de ce
côté quoi j'étais très très content j'ai
vu une redif d'un grand quiz been sport
m'a charles enfin peu importe les
équipes de omar da fonseca qu'à gagner
et du coup à la fin de l'émission il met
un petit chapeau là avec les petites
cloches des temples de bouffon et aux
couleurs bleu clair et blanc cheveux de
l'argentine albacete
ils ont mis diego en musique diego 10 et
aux marques des couilles de frottement à
fond quoi il sautait partout que ça
peut-être ses clochettes bloqués eux
aussi connaissent en fait la fête tout
le monde connaît je comprends bord je
pensais que sur le monde pas seul au
monde tiens je m mais comment je vais
faire pour faire du bruit avec cette
dure de ses toiles gaulle à m ça serait
dur à tunis est parti je vais plus en
cet endroit là je gagne celle là et je
me barre t'écoutes la mano je suis en
recul à l'élan humain tu veux ton petit
chapeau partout j'ai envie de faire un
truc dans l'esprit pour aller mater mais
je pouvais pas jean ramener une tour
mais l'entrevue un palace est blindé il
peut plus rien attaqué insérant dans
l'esprit du beats à quatre reprises elle
regarde il ne peut plus à attaquer tout
est défendu
dit manon de jeu car il veut le racheter
au fonds va tout gagner à chaussin
j'irai en des gaz non tu ne ferais tu
n'attaques rire john loos en kf3 en fait
tu crois tellement d'idées
si on lit des recherches ouais c'est
complètement gagnant je pense votre
future gs is when en décembre je
regrette étude qui montre les dents que
veut dire j'aï risson quoi et ben moi je
te pousse le pion à parts égales il se
coupe des cons c'est bien c'est un génie
en fait non on affine par une partie
dans l'esprit une partie d'anthologie à
une fantastique cette partie mais c'est
surtout le sacrifice de dames en fait
j'ai pas pris l'ouverture le reflet du
fantastique rennes c'est une partie ok
bon du coup du xistera banjar oignons
cinquième mis en tête car on n'a qu'à
5-4 aime bien karaté bien aujourd'hui
encore le le dembélé des échecs qu'on
peut dire et du coup on soit à tout le
monde une bonne soirée et on vous dit à
jeudi prochain pour des live et à
bientôt sur les vidéos allez allez